imaginemos que tenemos una función f
una función fx que está dada por un
polinomio digamos éste 5x al cuadrado
más 6 x más 5 este polinomio cuadrática
de activo y entonces el teorema
fundamental del álgebra me dice que este
polinomio tiene que tener dos raíces o
dos números x donde la función evaluada
en ese número vale 0 2 números x tales
que 5 x al cuadrado más 6 x + 5 en ese
número x es igual a 0 y los invito a
pasar este vídeo y tratar de encontrar
esos números asumiré que ya lo hicieron
y vamos a atacar el problema así a
simple vista a mí al menos no se me
ocurre qué números podrían ser o cómo
factorizar este polinomio así que voy a
utilizar la fórmula cuadrática y que me
hizo la fórmula cuadrática pues me dice
que voy a tratar de usar colores me dice
que menos b donde b
este número de aquí es el coeficiente de
la x que está elevado a la potencia 1 -
b en los 6 + - + menos
más o menos la raíz cuadrada
de b al cuadrado que sería 6 al cuadrado
menos 4 veces menos cuatro veces
donde a es este coeficiente de la x al
cuadrado
por c
donde se es este número de aquí
todo eso entre dos veces
dos veces
por 5
x igual a este número va a ser
precisamente van a ser precisamente las
raíces de este polinomio pero bueno
cuánto vale este número pues este número
va a ser que me parece algo los colores
menos 6 más menos la raíz cuadrada de
cuanto 6 al cuadrado 34 4 por 5 es 20
por 5 es 100 así que sería 34 menos 100
que sería menos 64 menos 64 a miguel un
número complejo entre 2 por 5 es 10
ahora esto es muy interesante porque
aquí
este número es negativo o dicho de otro
modo
dicho de otro modo el número de al
cuadrado menos 4 hace que normalmente le
llaman el discriminante de este pool y
no me cuadra tico es menor que cero por
lo tanto voy a tener raíces complejas
pero bueno veamos cuánto vale este
número pues va a ser menos 6 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de si extiendo la
definición de la raíz cuadrada hacia los
números complejos esto va a ser más o
menos 8 veces y donde i es la raíz
cuadrada de menos 1 todo dividido entre
10 de modo que las raíces de mi
polinomio van a ser x igual a menos 6 +
menos 8 y
entre 10
qué es lo mismo que aquí puedo dividir
todo entre dos y obtener menos tres
entre cuatro menos tres entre cinco más
menos
4 entre 5 x
o dicho de otro modo x va a ser igual a
menos tres quintos
más cuatro veces cuatro quintos de iu
o x es igual a menos tres quintos menos
cuatro quintos de ellos
así que en este caso es muy interesante
porque tengo estas raíces complejas en
el caso en el que este discriminante fue
menor que cero tengo estas dos raíces
complejas y ustedes pueden notar que
incluso son conjugadas estos dos números
complejos son conjugados lo cual se
origina de este más menos en la fórmula
cuadrática pero bueno vamos a verificar
gráficamente que en realidad este
polinomio no tiene raíces reales el
teorema en fundamental del álgebra aquí
me dice que tiene que tener dos raíces
que un polinomio de grado n tiene que
tener en raíces complejas pero pueden
ser reales o pueden ser complejas no
importa vamos a verificar gráficamente
ok ya con la calculadora vamos a
graficar la gráfica de igual a 5 x al
cuadrado más 6 x más 5 y vamos a cambiar
el rango vamos a cambiar el rango x
mínimo el mínimo de x en menos días creo
que está bien x máximo en 10 en la
escala de x está bien en 1 ahora la
vamos a poner la aie como esta función
crece muy rápido vamos a ponerla en 100
en vez de en 10
y de hecho vamos a cambiar la escala
para que sean cada 10
y vamos a cambiar esto al menos 20 ok
entonces veamos la gráfica como se ve
ahí está la gráfica y como ustedes notan
parece que no corta el eje y podría ser
un poco de zoom
de hecho al ser suma aquí está un poco
complicado mejor vamos a cambiar de
nuevo el rango vamos a ponerlo
de x igual a 20 y hasta 20 y vamos a
cambiar la escala a 2
todos me parece que así estaría bien
vamos a ver la gráfica creo que así se
va a acercar lo suficiente y si ahí lo
pueden ver ustedes la gráfica
definitivamente no corta al eje x por lo
tanto esta función no tiene ceros reales
sus dos raíces son los números complejos
que encontramos